I got a show for you sounds like it's on
history on demand yeah
is it the the with the things upon the
kings of pain its two gentlemen an
Australian and a former I think he's
like a marine or some [ __ ] okay and they
go around to do a score of pain oh I'll
do this take my second item oh yeah dude
I will I will watch dude they let a boa
constrictor buy them first like Haley's
been testing yeah that's not a big deal
to me compared to like the Scorpion
centipede spiders
but I mean I've been Baba watch this
would you save me a bit by snake yeah
what snake a Burmese python and also up
of course oh but not like these but yeah
ya know why does it really paint it's
more painful than the scorpion though
the tarantula hawk well I don't want to
ruin it you gotta watch it you know I
want a what's the most saintil thing for
them if you can watch Joe getting 391
the centipede that see these guys that
they the coyote Peterson said it was he
got sick or something but here's the
thing that that that locust tree that
bites them it latches on and they have
to get like 18 stitches in their [ __ ]
arm that's so wild wait I hate those
things scare me what is that horrifying
that's a centipede yeah they are
horrible for centipede [ __ ] you've
been all over the world have you seen
one of those in a while yes I have yeah
I I have now I seen one of those in the
wild I saw one of those in my house my
father killed one of those a huge one in
Lebanon with his bull show scary in his
book with his book yeah honey of the
book no remember I lived in Pakistan in
India there all those different
countries Philippines they get they get
bit by the little world what's the worst
like where nature's just so you're like
Fah Africa right well I forgot but you
know Pakistan and we there were cobras
we had cobras yeah we had did you charm
them all kinds of snakes in Asia like
that yeah I will bite it'll kill you and
your and if you're a kid you're a god
you know so yeah man sounds pretty bad
too yeah yeah let's go somewhere in the
Philippines though and they're just like
dude the Philippines they they catch
some sort of wasp in the Philippines and
you can tell they're not doing well dude
dude the Philippines talk to the
Philippines are sad because like I'm
very squeamish of this stuff all the
other show crap
really I'm gonna wash up both both the
hosts I'm gonna walk right together and
they get bit and they have a they have a
medical staff on-site when they get bit
by that centipede the one dudes like he
turns all white and he's like I gotta
lay down he goes can you tell it's
really just my [ __ ] do we do the show
why so what happens after he gets bit by
that do they just then shoot him up with
something okay
no antivenom know they gotta ride out
like there's this one I free what kind
of ride you like these guys could die a
hundred percent that's what I had a cool
staff on-site but the ratio but they're
back
oh so here so that there's a beetle
where it's toxic purr purr like drip is
way more venomous than a Cobra but the
way it gets to you is so you you the
it's in its blood so they they say this
beetle land on you people smash it I
don't think you think they smashed it
and then they just go about their day
but in his the toxins in his blood
that's what made all those so it's like
how sick is he exactly if we thought
this OP who's sitting in some room in
Beverly Hills I guess these why don't we
just have like insects bite people and
see if they live well you don't want
that's our new show what is that [ __ ]
thing right there oh dude that you're
talking about that wasp right that's a
transfer Hawk what's that thing the
Trent the tarantula hawk do they let any
spiders do it they have a transfer bite
them built the one with the big things
the Goliath yeah whoa that kills the
birds yeah right part eating spider
bites and it's but it's not that
venomous so they're probably okay but it
hurts like hell it hurts cuz it like you
can see it's weird you can hear it
piercing the skin go ahead what yeah
yeah those nose those boys are bad those
spiders are size of a dinner plate and
they'll wrap around here's the thing on
there's pain index they don't they do
initial pain then of the effects of the
bite and then how long it lasted dude
I'm gonna finish this when I you know
the simpie centipede that why is the
snakes number one to this the cent most
venomous was the centipede what happened
is the worst is it like when the
centipede bites you is just is it like
local or just like your whole body's
just they said their hope some you act
local so they give it a low score on the
overall and some it's just a some they
said last for days yeah
Sena beads like it's really dangerous
really bad for you it [ __ ] kills people
whole body oh you know what they did
they did us there's some sort of sea
urchin that's super poisonous and they
put their arms out and they have to get
to the they're short like little barbs
are the most poisonous so you have to
break this thing they're pushing it down
it's going to stitch and then they hit
it oh dude it's insane
would you let a centipede bite you to
reopen the economy yes I think I would I
would do a lot name anything right now
to him I would probably do it go yeah
[ __ ] I would a now if the counter is
booming and after we do this show my
girl goes how much how much would you
let how much would it take for you to do
this show it's like all right I don't
know cuz I'm so scared of that snake the
thing is you have a kid it's different
if you don't have a kid right cuz you
have a kid so it's like heart like I
surely have a motorcycle yeah you gotta
just there's certain things you have to
kind of like we all live with levels of
risk but this seems like a high level of
risk there's that sea urchin that thing
[ __ ] them yeah that dudes you pick
Barb's in them this [ __ ] and then the
barbs get under the skin I don't see you
don't wanna [ __ ] with this you can see
that you cannot mess with me that shows
fantastic throne fish I mean come on I
keep saying boys I want to see get bit
by a rattlesnake I know somebody's going
to tell you I've been watching the show
I want to see your bass dangerous over
there they're too dangerous it's a it's
a venom that that gives in your whole
body I mean there's certain things a
wall hero talked these guys won't do
like the little they won't go to
Australia some of the things like
there's some of the things you know
Australia little scorpion fish yeah but
they really they won't do the
blue-ringed octopus the blue-ringed all
the time they caught one and they go we
can't touch this you a doctor we would
die yeah but that's different
I don't want do an Amazon when those
Amazon frogs where if you eat them yeah
and you become trans that's kind of cool
yeah you've been driving a lot of
science I'm I've heard of bridge
geologists I saw you just said that I
know you are but I just said if you look
at you'll become trans not into a [ __ ]
lick it you know we have gender
dysphoria no longer want to be that
you're born gender okay do you have
documentation on this I am
vertebrate zoology I've seen this happen
in the why I understand do you have I
seen a man get licked by a frog and then
become a woman
by the way it's beautiful well the Frog
licks the man cuz I thought the man had
to lick the Frog there's a lot of
licking going on and that's exactly and
that's how you become a trans person hey
oh you know what they'd actually get
they get bit by the Velvet Bunny son did
that thought it was a cool aunt he heard
and that's why I'm in California oh it's
cutest [ __ ] that's what I said Judas
[ __ ] yo they are high I want to stop
don't though you know you're full of
[ __ ] huh they get bigger you like this
oh dang no that wasn't too bad
coyote said they were high all right
well here's they get they go no
imperative via comparatively these guys
getting bit by all kinds ah it's a brand
it's the new date you know they're
taking months up between bites they get
bitten they both kill not bad it's the
lowest on the score oh my god he goes
like a honey bees a one the things I
guess three for them so what about look
at that [ __ ]
so what is the worst wasp they say
besides trash flow uh can you bring it
up here they have mana file the
executioner wasp is ahead of the
transfer was what about like a great
white shark that should be seasoned
easily that'll take your leg off well
that's season two how are they gonna top
this there was a guy who wanted to put a
suit on like a giant white suit and [ __ ]
with a grizzly um it's a terrible idea
yeah but Dad I think he died well cuz
there's brick walls bones right snap his
neck well it was like really fortified
you know okay but yeah you're gonna get
[ __ ] would they let a person bite them
that season two that season to
developing up to three and a bullet
instead of four and that's the highest
so that's why I'm saying this is our
Angela
this is there what's a warrior wasp all
there's Horcher these your changes you
know why they come warrior wasps because
when they're on the when they're about
to tax them they start clapping their
wings that sounds like a tribe going all
at the same time nature's that shows
fantastic is that this is why I am for
companies destroying the planet because
these things need to go well well but
that's kind of a blanket shutdown is yes
there are some cute furry things that
I'm gonna go as well but a lot of these
things are gonna you gonna have one pet
what would it be oh great question I
enjoy the capybara far as a good [ __ ]
the largest rodent rodent it's just a
fun conversation starter it is adorable
tell me you would not walk around there
even there's a favorite dish of the
non-whites people but they're also
Africa yeah but they're all know that
Worthen dishes - and Amazon Amazon the
Amazon so they are they favorite dish of
the spear chuckers because in the Amazon
that's not a racist they have tribes
okay they do yeah but that's they do the
dead but there's a Mazzoni animal that
loves a couple yeah the Condor dealer
yacon oh no crocodiles Tiger Tigers
aren't part of the Anaconda they're not
there they're not there the Jaguar guys
the young Wow oh yeah Yonghwa right okay
you listen look at how cute he is look
at her teeth tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]